stevie is with us in erie pennsylvania
hi stevie welcome to the dave ramsey
show
hi thank you how can we help
well my question is regarding choosing a
financial partner
looking towards marriage
okay so currently i'm in
a serious relationship you know we're
both pursuing a longer goal
but i've noticed some things that are
red flags i would say
and i'm not sure if i'm being over
critical in it or just
being attentive to the situation so this
individual
for instance there are a couple examples
i can give one of them is if we were to
both go out to a restaurant
this person's been unemployed for the
past nine months
you know they will order the most
expensive item
on the menu every single time when they
are being paid for but when it's my turn
to pay you know it's
i always pick the cheapest keeping in
mind the fact that we're both students
and i'm also working currently
the second example would be he just
graduated
and he took two months to get persuaded
into
looking for jobs seriously and now that
he's found one within three days he's
already considering quitting
me it just means a bit of a red flag
stevie how long have you all been
together
uh about eight months how old are you
guys
i'm sorry what was that how old are you
guys i am 27
and he is about to be 26. okay
stevie i'm going to tell you something i
think i don't i think whenever you have
those red flags and and
these things that you're talking about
and looking at these are things that i
think there are probably more
that you could allude to if we really
pressed and talked
i'm going to tell you you're probably
dealing with someone that's not
motivated
and this to me could sound like it could
end up being a project for you
later in life on many other fronts um
i i i would move on i really and truly
would
uh because you want someone that that's
that's that's equal with you that wants
to
chase and conquer and work together as a
team
right now in the row boat you're the
person that's rowing and he's relaxing
and and i don't think that that's the
kind of life you want long term for you
and your
in your own legacy yeah
and also it's a concern too when a lot
of people hear my major
they're like oh you're going to make
money but they don't realize the
investment that's gone into it
and the work that's gone behind like
funding my own education
yeah well you're a driven person you're
motivated
you've got things that you want to
accomplish and i i don't think there's
anything with allowing this individual
to be a good friend
uh but i i would move on if i were you i
think you've seen enough red flags to
let you know
something's not quite right here
you know sometimes sometimes a way to uh
it's a little tough for us in a
two-minute radio call to
dictate the next decade of your future
with a relationship situation but
uh a couple things pop into my mind just
hearing your story and listening to you
uh there's no question you're a very
goal-oriented person you have a lot of
initiative and a lot of drive
and so you're and you're self-aware
enough to know i could be overly
concerned about this i could be a little
bit legalistic about it
and that's good to worry about that a
little bit to be you know to
on your part you don't want to be a you
know be a jerk on every little detail
right but the things that you the second
thing that you mentioned
um unemployed for nine months
finally does get a job uh and then
immediately hates the job and wants to
quit
uh you know it just that one sounds a
lot more serious than just
the the price of your entree um
you know and the the lack of manners
around ordering the expensive thing when
you're not paying
manners i mean if you if if we told
somebody not to get married based on
manners
sharon wouldn't have ever married me i
didn't have any manners still don't have
a lot but she's taught me a few
um but the uh um i finally figured out
which
fork and all that stuff but the uh
but uh so one two two things pop into my
head that i always
think of when i'm in situations like
yours
um three things i had another one pop
into my head
one is a buddy of mine says when there's
something bothering you down inside
when your spirit is disturbed there's a
reason
and your spirit's disturbed and that's
why you called
and you're just looking for someone to
confirm to you that
it's okay to have a disturbed spirit and
he always says when in doubt
don't so if a deal feels funny if i'm
working on a business deal
or a client and it feels funny
there's a reason it feels funny that
there's something really going on there
you know and that's not that is not to
be discounted
um and so that that concerns me about
your situation
uh the second thing is there's a book
that my friend henry cloud did
called necessary endings when do you end
a relationship of any kind when you end
a relationship where you
like you say i'm going to quit a job or
i'm going to do a breakup
or i'm going to end a marriage or i'm
going to
end this friendship when do you end a
relationship
it is when you lose hope that the thing
of concern is
never going to get any better and the
the character qualities that you've lack
of character that you've outlined
falls in that category and so
when in doubt don't and then the last
thing that popped into my head was this
ask yourself because you're wise beyond
your ears
15 20 years from now your teenager girl
your teenage daughter is sitting in
front of you
and she asks you this exact question
what are you going to tell her about
this boyfriend
and that one that may end it for him
no i mean because that he may be done
when you ask me yeah i mean
that pulls yourself out of the middle of
it and now you're looking and talking to
someone you love
in other words does the 35 year old you
yeah
have respect for the 27 26 year old you
wow
when you look back and you go whoo
dodged a bullet on that one or
hey i'm glad i didn't overreact to a
couple of little things that's right
that's a good one of the two ways
oh that's a great perspective and just
back up from it a little bit
and so those are three things that i use
i look for that kind of a thing
and say you know long term
am i going to be glad i did this right
because if you back off and say long
term is this a good investment
long term am i glad that
when i'm 75 years old i mean uh we're if
we're negotiating severance with
somebody that we've let go here
right and a few dollars makes it
better that the pain of someone leaving
the building
i'm never going to regret those few
dollars on my bed on my deathbed when
i'm 78
right that's great uh and and i would
regret that a
relationship was ruined that didn't need
to be rude right wow
long-term perspective